Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. Here
is a blowing voicemail with a hypothesis about
how I didn't get COVID, but my girlfriend did,
as I talked about last week. I don't know that
anything in this voicemail is based on science,
but it is an entertaining hypothesis.
Let's listen to it together.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I listened to your show on
your girlfriend with great exposure and I have a
possible solution for you. It wasn't an issue of
her instructing you with an issue of you infecting
her. OK? Your brother and you share the same
genetics. In all probability, you picked it up
from your brother. What I'm finding here around
me is that people that have got high levels of
protection are still picking up the virus, and
they can still extrude virus in micro doses,
essentially. How to think about it.
Speaker 1: Extrusion of micro doses?
Speaker 3: Wow. But they're not producing enough
for the viral protein to trigger the COVID tests.
So in your situation where you're your girlfriend
seemed better than worse, better than worst
type of situation. What I think happened
was your brother infected, you guys when
you were in the car, when you went home. Her
genetics responded her way. Your projection
engine that is responded this way and so is
your brother. You obviously share the same.
Speaker 1: So all of this is absolutely
fascinating and entertaining. I don't know
that there's anything here based in science, so
like one idiot. First of all, the idea that it's
my brother who was the exposure point my brother
tested, tested, tested. After this, it doesn't
seem like he had COVID. It doesn't seem like he
had it, nor that he got it. The other thing is.
I don't know that there's any evidence that
if you're exposed by someone with whom you
share genetic material like a brother, that you're
less likely to get it from them than an exposure
from a person with whom you don't share genetic
material, it's endlessly entertaining. I just
don't know that there's any facts here.
Speaker 3: Very similar. So during that
time frame, you were sick, you weren't
sick enough to actually produce enough
protein to trigger the positive test.
Speaker 1: She was remembered the test
is looking at viral RNA, not viral protein,
as we talked about yesterday. So there's some
some question marks here about this explanation.
Speaker 3: Reacting to that because you guys
both work from home and you're both in such
a closed space and you're living as a couple,
you essentially were microdosing her on
a regular basis. So it was a situation of
very little over a long period of time.
That's why she had her ups and downs.
Speaker 1: It's fascinating. I don't know that
there's anything there that's actually backed
by science, but a fascinating, fascinating
explanation on today's bonus show. The U.S.
Russia talks have ended and no progress has been
made. We will also talk about the first ever
heart transplant from a genetically edited pig.
Fascinating. And Jon Ossoff will introduce a bill
banning members of Congress from owning from
trading individual stocks. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Sign up it.
Unidentified: Join Pacman Scott and we
will see you then.